what's happening reject nation we're
gonna watch this video today that cosmic
wonder uploaded it just sounds like one
that seems super duper fun
tom holland almost spoiled spider-man 3
spider-verse he knew the whole time
tom holland almost spoiling stuff is the
highlight
of tom holland the mcu
uh any chance there's a multiverse in
which andrew garfield spider-man and
children acquire spider-man and her
first automatic
all meet together i mean
wow that little look is enough to make
you go
with what we have yeah i
now there are some very exciting things
coming up like the release of the one
division series on disney plus oh yeah
january 15th series is filming right now
and haley steinfeld is confirmed to be
playing kate bishop and we have
many leaked photos and videos but no
matter what every day people are talking
about spider-man 3
and the spider-verse now at this point
it's pretty much confirmed that it is in
fact going to be a spider-verse film oh
yeah many different
words than that from other universes in
fact there are going to be at least
five other characters from different
universes and i'll cover that in a video
later on
but today we're going to talk about the
fact that tom holland
totally knew about the spider verse
happening way back
in 2019 during the release of spider-man
far from home and today we have a video
that totally
proves it from jake hamilton totally
jake's
take so we're gonna break down
everything you need to know be sure to
subscribe if you're new
it's a good good interviewer sam jackson
tried to get him to say the n-word once
it's a fun interview
interviewing life for django unchained
with tom holland jacob babylon and
zendaya with
jake hamilton so in this interview jake
hamilton starts talking about
into the spider-verse and then he
mentions that spider-man far from home
also kind of talks about the multiverse
which they did
mysterio did say that he was from a
different universe and he even said
earth 616 is the main universe now of
course that ended up being a lie but
spider-man far from home did bring up
the multiverse yes but then jake goes on
to ask about the next spider-man film
and if there's any chance that we would
see other spiderman show up
uh any chance there's a multiverse in
which andrew garfield spiderman and tim
mcguire spider-man and her new starter
man
all meet together clashing
and then you sort of just say
well would you want that would you want
that maybe that's a better question
you could see
and answer in and him itself the thing
about this film that's so exciting right
if you take spiderman to europe and
what's so
really really cool so he asked this
question and then it cuts to
jacob tom and zendaya and as he asks
this question you can look at
tom's face and he looks like he's
absolutely terrified that he's going to
accidentally spoil something for the
next spider-man film which is really
playing with his thumbs too
he's asking these questions he starts
fiddling around with his hands he's
playing with his thumbs
and it just looks like he's completely
freaking out and the reason he's
freaking out is because he knows he
knows that the next
he's got that look in his eye yeah this
makes sense that they were planning a
live action spider verse for a pretty
long time as well
and as the interview goes on it becomes
fairly obvious that tom really is trying
not to spoil it oh it's obvious yeah i
could answer
after jake asked the question tom
literally says nothing
he's completely silent while jacob and
zendaya talk about what that would be
like
then ultimately jake would end up asking
him if his no answer is an answer in and
of itself
then tom completely ignores the question
he says the thing about this film
speaking about spider-man far from home
the thing that's so exciting is that we
take spider-man to europe and then he
kind of acts like he's
thinking and he actually does address it
and he gives a typical
cookie-cutter answer of somebody who
definitely knows that it's happening but
of course
can't reveal anything but ultimately he
does end up saying
yes that would be amazing that would be
amazing it would be really really cool
it's something that the fans really want
so whether marvel and sony decide to do
that
um it's not up to me
like kevin this is what we're doing on
the next one yeah but it would be really
good
so this is pretty funny i think it's
hilarious that tom holland was asked
this over a year ago
kind of froze on the spot because he
definitely knew that it was happening
but then played it off
it was a cool idea but let's face it
when you have a movie that's as big as
this movie is going to be
the spider-verse a live-action
spider-verse and the multiverse in the
mcu you plan it for a very long time
it's not just whipped together over the
course of a year
i don't know they just started casting
toby maguire and everything
since the past couple of months they're
just signing people now
they've been cast for a while the road
with his spiderman ultimately going on
to meet up with
the other spider-man toby mcguires and
he's talking to that guy's throat
here and i'm really surprised that jake
hamilton is actually the only person to
really ask him in an interview about
this
of course everybody knows now it's no
surprise but it honestly is a pretty big
shocker that tom holland never spoiled
it
but recently way to give him credit
be sure to subscribe so you don't miss
out on any of the latest news and look
out for my next video talking more about
some pretty big news about the spider
verse hit the like button if you enjoyed
this video and for live updates you can
always follow me on instagram and
twitter
as always thank you all so much for
watching woof thank you
warren for putting this together guys if
you haven't seen our video with warren
cosmic wonder we're talking about
spider-man black panther two it's a fun
podcast
wacky one make sure to go check that out
matt's getting to the point with this
spider-man movie where you
have to start counting who's not in this
film
jane jahan james franco who has
who is not signed on oh yeah looking at
this especially now with what we know
it does seem apparent but what stood out
to me more was it seemed like
zendaya and jake battle on it seemed
like they knew
too and they were both like stop we will
handle this
for the sake of all of our careers don't
say anything tom we know you're on the
verge of saying something partly why
they paired us
with you in case anything like this
should come up
but it also does make me wonder
about was this part of the trouble that
was going
on with the sony marvel deal when they
weren't
together with each other was that did
they know that they wanted to do
segway into a live-action spider-verse
movie next
and in order to do that we would need
tom holland to appear with the other
sony spider-man characters and was
marvel like i don't know about this was
it really just a money issue how did tom
holland feel
being like well damn i thought we were
gearing up for the next cute biggest mcu
movie ever
and now that would happen yeah it makes
me wonder like what would the discu
i hope i'm really hoping that once this
spider-man 3 movie does come out in some
way someone is able to unveil more
information about that because
they didn't want tom holland to appear
alongside with venom at some point man
we haven't
even asked ourselves questions about
that like will venom make an appearance
like this
we forgot about all of this
like madness and and the thing is i
really am becoming fascinated with
i mean we talk about a lot of movie news
and i feel like we've been
observing this fish bowl for long enough
to know a little bit about what we're
talking about that's right our fishbowl
helmet it also makes me wonder like you
know
there are tons of truths none of us are
privy to about how these things
actually went down and this is one
instance in which yeah absolutely when
this movie comes out i
hope someone writes like a book or does
like a little documentary about like
what happened in all these meetings what
was the truth because you know i mean
there's so much speculation and one
thing we've been saying with all this
casting news is
some of this has to be already inked and
they're just
trickling down for like now especially
with how
fast this information is rolling out i
just think it's been a delay
in information or they're slowly letting
stuff leak you know i think it's a smart
way to get the
people excited for the mcu again
especially with
uh you know the wand division show
coming out i think that all it all
it's all part of the plan so
guys what do you want tom holland to
spoil next
yeah what secret would you what's
happening and uncharted how does chaos
walking end
subscribe to cosmic wonder if you
haven't done so already subscribe to the
real rejects please click that
notification bell to get notified when
our next video was up last not least
got a shout out my friend jason dolan
he's been an incredible help to me
anytime
i give him a call doesn't matter what
time of day morning noon or night he
knows
to pick up his phone right away one of
the most reliable friends in the world
also an editor producer for the channel
cazzy reacts we're over there
cazzy just put up very recently a
reaction
to the movie spider-man into the
spider-verse views are
great on this video her reaction is
wonderful do yourself a favor
go check out this reaction i guarantee
you you will enjoy it if you are
into the spider-verse fan thank you
jason and subsequently
thank you cazzy see you guys